deux ans de prison un ferme un avec
sursis c'est le jugement rendu ce matin
en l'absence de l'ex juge dijonnais il
bénéficiera d'un aménagement de peine et
pour allah réalisée à son domicile sous
surveillance électronique
la condamnation comprend également une
obligation de soins l'interdiction
d'exercer une activité professionnelle
ou bénévole en lien avec les mineurs et
une inscription sur le fichier est ce le
fichier des délinquants sexuels cette
avocate défend les intérêts de la fille
du magistrat se félicite de la
condamnation et de la prochaine
expertise sur celle ci
c'est très intéressant que auprès le
temps d'une expertise pour voir où il en
est si un préjudice important et
royalement important par rapport à ce
qui lui a été dit ou pas dit et
l'instant que ça c'est très intéressant
pour la reconstruction de cette jeune
fille en juillet dernier cet ancien vice
président du tribunal judiciaire avait
été révoqué de sa fonction de magistrat
un recours avait alors été déposée pour
la condamnation d'aujourd'hui un appel
sera-t-il fait la défense de l'ex juge
n'a pour l'instant pas répondu à nos
sollicitations
mais lors du procès elle avait plaidé la
relaxe le délibéré est donc tombé
l'ex-juge dijonnais est reconnu coupable
pour ces faits mais le paradoxe dans
cette affaire c'est que la fille de ses
textes juge vit toujours au domicile la
familiale avec son père et ce depuis le
début de la faire